ces familles ont fuit leur pays en
raison de la violence et de la guerre
après des mois d'errance à partir de
l'amérique latine
ils ont finalement abouti ici c'est le
cas de philippe qui est parti de la
république démocratique du congo avec sa
femme et ses quatre enfants pour passer
la forêt des panamas colombie panama
c'est là où on a passé vraiment la
souffrance si les schémas j'avais même
eu des morts il ya des gens qui sont la
mort jusqu'à maintenant et je plais
l'équipe du congo pour l'angola de
l'angola au brésil
et puis à pas sûrs du brésil il commence
à avancer à mes panama mexique jusqu'à
ce qu'ils atteignent les frontières du
site de l'amérique
la ville de portland leur offre un abri
et des road pas grâce à des dons de 400
mille dollars en provenance de 30 états
américains en plus de services aux
femmes enceintes
ces demandeurs d'asile ont choisi des
émirats portland parce qu'il existe déjà
il communauté africaine issue moi je
pense que les réseaux et les gens vont
s'appeler et ça va continuer mais
combien de temps vont-ils encore rester
ici beaucoup d'entre eux songent déjà à
remonter vers le canada d'ailleurs les
autorités canadiennes le confirme ils
ont vu beaucoup de congolais traversé la
frontière ces derniers jours
si j'arrive aux états unis il faut aller
au canada
pas tout le monde bien sûr mais il ya ya
il y aura toujours ces trafics là entre
les états unis et le canada
cette bénévole le confirme beaucoup
d'entre eux veulent se rendre au canada
les autres disent qu'ils veulent rester
ici et les autres disent qu'ils veulent
partir là bas au canada
et pourquoi ils veulent aller au canada
pour l'anglais parce qu'ils aiment pas
apprendre l'anglais ici de disques et de
pointer sais pas si on y disent qu'ici à
porter bien pour eux parce que c'est à
côté de montréal
si le policier dpolg n'égale pas ils
vont traverser là bas au canada
c'est d'ailleurs l'intention de philippe
si les etats-unis lui refuse l'asile si
on vous refuse l'asile ici qu'est ce que
vous faites chez les ch et wallons je
vais te quitte la maison ici catherine
kovacs radio-canada portland dans le
maine